welcome to the amber ruffin show you
guys
you're never going to believe it this is
the only late-night show that's written
entirely in crayon
i can't believe i have to say this but
stop getting mad about spoilers if you
don't want me to spoil something for you
watch it it's a pandemic i know you have
time
i have two drugs and i have time and
this goes double for things that have
been out for a while
there's no such thing as a harry potter
spoiler
it came out 19 years ago although
spoiler the lady who wrote it is
transphobic
you let amber ruffin into your living
rooms every friday night
but when she's not on your tv do you
know what she's thinking
or better yet do you know what she's
doing
because amber ruffin is planning to eat
your pets
and don't take it from me here's amber
in her own words
and i can't wait to meet you are pets i
don't even
eat lizards amber ruffin and nike
lizards i wish i could stop
climate change
whoa i wish everyone in the world could
just get along with everyone
except nicki minaj because i love it
when she has beef
whoa another shooting star whoa i wish i
could fly
any airline for free regardless of my
miles
[Music]
i wish a mother would
whoa they were planning on kidnapping
the governor
in a pt cruiser please stop your made-up
nonsense it's true you're grown-ass men
planning a kidnapping in a pt cruiser
where you gonna take her 2010 a pt
cruiser
who is planning this kidnapping the mom
some big little lies
a pt cruiser why don't you p.t cruise
that car into the trash where it belongs
the pt stands for painful truth and the
painful truth is that you look like a
fool driving that car
if your costume is an ethnicity
then you're a piece of [ __ ]
an uncreated and weirded freaking
walking turd
and now everybody knows it
so take your headdress sombrero and
blackened face
throw em in the garbage be your own damn
race
cause this halloween party is not the
place for your casual racism
relax breathe think
happy thoughts about a gorgeous
sunrise a field of
roses a baby dressed
like a bumblebee a cool car
on a hot summer day a parking spot
right in front of your house
a little girl winning a karate contest
hey president trump's campaign held a
press conference on saturday at the four
seasons total landscaping
because what better way to end a
campaign than at a place
that literally spreads manure hey
trump's campaign held a press conference
on saturday at four seasons total
landscaping
four seasons that's four more seasons
than trump has left
as president
[Music]
let's listen to a black woman song yeah
i i heard it it was like oh this is um
this is um it's not a song that exists
it's just his own
you
[Laughter]
me and tarik are going to sing all of
these you better listen to it
you better tell me who you gotta listen
to black
she would listen to you too but she
would disappoint
why are they playing lethal weapon music
[Music]
but she is really running she's really
running for
really running they didn't tell her that
no and those
cars i i realize it's a movie and it's
all
uh choreographed but i thought she was
gonna die so did she
[Laughter]
tonight you will be visited by three
ghosts
i will what what
don't you bring any ghosts around here i
swear to god i will beat the [ __ ] out of
a ghost i dare you
you ain't your little friends well i
just wanted to warn you
here's your warning do you want to die a
second time
trying to harm me [ __ ] terry do you see
this mess
yeah how you running around threatening
people when you ain't even alive
with your dusty ass look just cause
you're dead don't mean you can't get
your ass whooped
can't wait to go stuff 20 20 what a year
so full of crushing sorrow we counted
down the days until we found a new
tomorrow
the time has come for 21 and 20s finally
ended but it would be a lie to say that
some things were not splendid
we all got into tiger king that looks at
our affections and who could forget
donald trump lost the election
and there's uh the
the other thing that happened is uh
there's uh starting on january 20th
democrats will have control of the house
the senate and the white house for the
first time in over a decade
do you know what this means we might
actually get
a health care system a real health care
system and i might be able to get this
mole looked at
what this means do you do you know what
this means
we can finally do something about
climate change like what
like this whoa
is this helping i don't know but we can
finally do this
yeah come on
[Music]
ohio state cancels football game against
illinois amid virus outbreak
i am tired of virus outbreaks you know
what we need
an outbreak of manners please and thank
you
oh my baby i remember mama oh
kamala harris receives coronavirus
vaccination
oh she has time to get the vaccine but
she doesn't have time to call me back
okay she's very busy mom is he doing
what i'm busy
okay the question is amber
you partying for what now top 10 answers
on the board
there's only one answer on the board
that's right
they unanimously agreed that there's
only one good answer as to why you'd be
partying
in a pandemic okay easy a wedding
nope a wedding can be postponed or in a
worst case scenario done
over zoom what about a christmas party
granny didn't put covid on the wish list
and if she did you know she just
returned it for store credit
steven tyler the lead singer of
aerosmith wanted to enjoy
a nice evening with some close friends
so he invited all his band mates over
to watch a movie stephen tyler pops the
movie in sits on the couch and gets
ready for the ride of his life
but there's a problem everyone else is
still hanging out
there's a full-blown conversation going
on during the opening credits
was stephen tyler starting to get
frustrated steven tyler couldn't take it
anymore
what did he say he said guys i don't
wanna miss a thing
you're reclaiming my time damn it the
capital
was desecrated desperate
the confederate flag was bandied about
discriminated
that didn't even happen in this capital
during the civil war
obliterator that's an insurrection
it's an infection
that's addition it's their tradition
that's undemocratic i find it dramatic
that's problematic
harriet's dream the true story of what
motivated one of the greatest women in
history
miss tubman i owe you everything
i'll honor your memory by working every
day of my life
to end our oppression or could you get
my face on the 20.
i don't see how it's easy i made a
prototype
you see it potatoes
potatoes
potatoes are boys they have and balls
potatoes can't be girls cause they don't
hang out in mall
if you think veggies can't be gendered
then you have failed
spuds have a gender and that gender is
male
1 potatoes
potatoes
let me get this straight let me get this
straight black people can say the n-word
but
i can't shout the different ethnicities
of people as they get onto the bus
so let me get this right let me get this
straight people can work a professional
job with a big old afro
and i'm not allowed to hide little
snacks in there i mean what
let me get this straight genitals don't
equal gender but
i'm not allowed to hold on to my
ding-dong at the groceries
let me get this let me get this straight
the bachelor can have a house full of
beautiful women fawning over them
but i attempt to do that and suddenly
i'm the star of a hbo max documentary
about a mediocre cult
you should listen to a black woman about
andrew cuomo
stop being surprised that white men
empower abuse power please pick new
idols
the only celebrity i believe in is
angela bassett and you should too
next covent vaccine i haven't wanted
anything inside of me this bad since i
was a kid
and my aunt told me i couldn't get an
easter basket unless i accepted christ
into my heart
not where you thought i was going with
that one next paddington three
they better not that movie up i swear to
god next
sesame street introduced two new black
muppets
this week to help facilitate discussions
of racism and black identity
which must have been a bummer for the
new black muppets
can we just do counting oh oh
re relive the drama all right
s is for systemic racism
come to think of it this was a white man
holding my
what the [ __ ] is this this was the week
i hit the wall problems couldn't solve
them all
i failed and failed this was the week i
fell behind kind of sort of lost my mind
worked
at the pace of a snail sounds terrible
to us
had a bad day on monday and tuesday and
wednesday
on thursday i cried i had a bunch of bad
feelings and i just couldn't keep them
all inside
this week was the week i hit the wall
oh yeah i've been there here we go this
is my personal
lowest note one time i ordered
mcdonald's delivery even though
mcdonald's is literally the closest
business to my home whoa
that was low all right let me uh let me
try
[Music]
one time i couldn't find my remote so i
just watched the 700 club for four weeks
straight
one time i cried at the end of an
episode of spongebob
five months after election day there are
still a lot of people who can't believe
donald trump lost
well lots of republicans and there's a
good reason
republicans can't believe trump lost the
election because they worked
so hard to rig it for him and they're
already trying to rig the next one
in fact just yesterday the florida
legislature passed a law to do
just that how did we end up in a
democracy with so many rigged elections
let's find out in a segment called how
did we get here
republican senator tim scott said
recently that
america is not a racist country and
president biden
and vice president harris agreed with
him
now i'm going to pretend like that news
story doesn't exist
is that healthy no tarik nothing i do is
healthy
some news i take to heart
some news i just dismissed
but some news is just so bad
baby i pretend it doesn't exist
i'm going to be the first person of
course do something
sick
[Music]
look at me i'm the first person to color
to do this
i'm the first person of color to do this
[Music]
i'm the first person of color to say no
thank you
that's too much flavor
i'm the first person of color to say
cool beans
[Music]
hey amber what is that
hey amber ruffin i uh
i think it's coming from the mail slot
amber mildred roofing
come on out here oh my god it's marjorie
taylor grain
marjorie i am not coming out there why
not
because i'm pretty sure you're gonna try
to murder me i
am a peacock subscriber i'll pay your
salary
you pay peacock's monthly subscription
fee well no i have the free version
authorities in kansas arrested a man
after he allegedly attacked a grocery
store worker during an argument about
chick-fil-a sauce
and it's a good thing they caught him
because he was about to dip
oh
oh man when you're black and you get
your own little show
and you get to do black puns
oh my god he's gonna fill up your heart
yeah
why did the vice president tell
guatemalans not to come to the u.s
because she's looking out for them she's
not telling them not to come to the u.s
because we don't want them
she's telling them that the u.s is not
the best place for them to be
so you're saying they shouldn't come
because the u.s is bad oh we're great we
invented airplanes in the internet so
you're saying they should come because
the u.s is good
no we're terrible we invented reality tv
in the opioid crisis
so the u.s is bad no it's great we have
over 14 000 mcdonald's
so the u.s is good no it's terrible we
have over 14 000 mcdonald's
if you're like me you're up way past
your bedtime so here's a little lullaby
to help you
get to sleep tonight
close your eyes and clear your mind
of all the things that bug you
and remember even if you're vexed
i don't want to
hug you that's the end of our show
thanks for watching
you